- Hi, I'm Ismael, I'm 29,
I'm a penetration tester.
- Whoa, I want to ask
you what pisses you off
but I gotta know, what
is a penetration tester?
- I'm a professional hacker
and criminal, basically.
- A criminal, do you not
know how cameras work?
- (clicks)
- (laughs) This is not the
dark web, this is real life,
the camera is on you.
- Eh, the government pays me.
Since you're a hacker, you
know, you go deeper online
than any of us, what is it
online that pisses you off?
The phrase "life hacks."
- Aha, because it
disrespects what you do.
- Yeah, I mean cutting an
apple in half is not a hack,
it's a thing people
have done, right?
- Right, cutting an
apple is not a hack,
it disrespects
what I do, which is
robbing a family of all
their livelihood online.
- Ah, no, they don't
have enough money,
I'm going after the
biggies (laughs).
When a person is
life-hacker, you're like,
"Fuck off, poseur, I mean,
I robbed Merrill Lynch."
- I did not.
- Oh yeah, he did not
rob Merrill Lynch.
Can you tell me what
government agency you work for?
- Nooo.
- Whoa, Ismael is a
straight up, degenerate,
illegitimate hacker
working for the government.
He got Jeff Sessions
all over him.
- That guy's weird.
- You think you could hack into
my stuff and take my money?
- Yes.
- I don't have that much.
- But you're cute.
- I'm cute, Ismael.